this is the reason interview with Nick
[Music]
[Applause]
gesp all right thanks for coming out
this is part of reason's little singer
series of salons and our guest tonight
is James kchi the author most recently
of the book Secret City the hidden
history of gay Washington we're going to
be talking to him about his work uh and
his career and his commitments to free
speech you define yourself Jamie uh
which is how you go by you define
yourself as a free speech
absolutist yeah yeah um why don't we
start by tell me how do what does that
mean like because you obviously don't
believe in free speech always being
legal do you I support the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution I've never heard of which
is uh the most expansive in terms of any
law of any country in the world and
basically permits any speech that is
short of inciting imminent violence or
could be or harassment right yeah short
of that um I think we should have a
pretty wide birth uh you uh recently
turned 40 years old so you are what a
millennial technically I turned 40 yes
uh on the inside you're obviously much
older um but why I mean so Millennials
and even worse gen Z are there any gen Z
in the audience okay look at one uh
um but um why are you a free speech
absolutist your generation does not
believe in free speech
anymore I mean I I maybe trace it back
to I think when I was in sixth grade and
I read
1984 and I wasn't really politically
aware of anything or or
much until that point um and that book
just sort of opened up a world to me it
sort of it taught me what the Cold War
was uh it was great literature it taught
me what Freedom meant it taught me what
author it arianism was I think the next
year I joined Amnesty International
which was a very different organization
we're talking like almost 30 years ago
was a very different organization it was
mostly concerned with you you write
letters to dictatorships to free
political prisoners so every week it'd
be some new you know some uh uh person
in some bited land and it was literally
you'd write like you know dear uh
commandante uh you know Warz or
something like Please Release this
writer from jail
um and then I also actually think I
think being a closeted gay person from
you know until I was 18 I think it's
your secret not anymore not anymore but
I think being in the closet from you
know until I was 18 um taught me the
value of expression and honesty and in
in speaking your truth I hate that term
but uh well because it's become a sort
of form of relativism you know my truth
there is a truth right but anyway I
think being
um understanding what it means to have
to lie about yourself about something so
integral to who you are it just made me
very sensitive to this issue I mean in
my book Secret City I compare sort of
the plight of gay men and women in
America 50 60 years ago to that of
dissidents in a communist country
because their Bars were raided by the
police their phones were tapped by the f
they had to live a lie they had to
pretend to be something that they
weren't and so I really do think that
being gay and and sort of you know
suffering in the closet in high school
and whatnot made me much more uh
supportive of of free speech um I guess
a couple things while you're talking um
I realize I have a lot of bills that I
need to pay um you know other things in
my mind came up that that was a joke
that obviously did not go over right you
should host the Golden Globes have you
thought about that know I turned that
down for this if you can imagine right
um but um what why was it difficult to
come out and what made it easy there or
not easy but what well I first of all
Everything's Relative and you know I I
grew up in a very you know pretty
liberal accepting household I was very
lucky in that sense I went to an all boy
school um which you know all male
environments tend to be more homophobic
because it's all homophilic my high
school was not it was uh um but you know
it's a kind of you know bravado and you
know proving you're not gay is very much
a part of those kinds of environments I
think a lot by the way has changed in
the 22 years since I mean everyone's
coming out now at 12 or 13 it seems like
half half of gen Z is LGBT I don't
believe that for a second by the way
okay but that's what it says according
to the polls it's actually it's
incredible when you think of the the
dramatic change where being gay or LGBT
queer whatever ter term you want to use
was considered a bad thing a terrible
thing a sin and whatnot and now it's
like if you're not you're you're awful
right or you're not cool you're not
interesting right and so that's that's a
strange somewhat positive there are also
negative aspects to that as well in
secret uh in secret City you talk about
how you the book that you wrote and the
history you wrote was possible because
of the people who came before you oh
absolutely yeah and um you know how did
they how did kind of Gay Liberation I
guess this is a good way to talk about
this in conjunction with free speech and
Frank camon is kind of the patron saint
of free speech as well as of Gay
Liberation could you talk a little bit
about how his life kind of illustrates
what you're talking about yeah I mean
Frank Cy was a PhD trained har Harvard
trained astronomer this is back when
Harvard was a great University when it
was a state school when before was an
extension scho right yeah um who was
working for the Army map service in 1957
which was the predecessor to the
geospatial intelligence agency and you
have to understand this is just a couple
months after Sputnik is launched into
space right so it's the height of the
Space Race he's working at an
observatory out in Hawaii and he's
summoned back to Washington and he's
fired on the spot because they have
evidence that he's gay this is during
what was called the lavender scare which
was a a purge of gay men and women from
the federal government it rivaled the
the Red Scare that was going on at the
same time in terms of numbers of of
victims and what Frank and you have to
understand there were thousands of
people up to this point who had lost
their jobs who had been fired who just
sort of slunk off into anonymity because
being publicly identified as a
homosexual in 1957 was a you know it was
it was career death what Frank did that
was so remarkable was he decided you
know what I'm going to actually
challenge this I'm going to take it to
court and what's interesting is that he
tried to get the ACLU to take his case
the ACLU would not take his case the
ACLU would take the cases of people who
were accused of Communism or actually
were communist they would not take the
case of a homosexual in
1957 he tries to get the Supreme Court
to overturn it they reject it he goes on
to form the madine society which is the
first real sustained gay rights
organization in the United States they
hold the first gay rights demonstration
outside the White House in 1965 but
every step along the way every um
significant progress that was made came
because of the First Amendment right I
mean these were people who were
considered the most desp able people in
America they were perverts they were
sexual deviants but they had a First
Amendment right to express themselves
and it was through that that you know
over a pretty remarkably short period of
time when you consider the full sweep of
American History to go from 1965 having
a demonstration outside the White House
just advocating that people not be fired
for being gay 50 years later to having
the Supreme Court approved gay marriage
Supreme Court be 50% gay well yeah
although they're still in the closet
right I don't know about that no I think
they're all they're all Jews they're all
Jews and Catholics yeah now then that's
a big problem and a lot of them are from
New Jersey don't even get me started um
no but that is amazing uh to think about
and cam himself was an outspoken
defender of free speech and the First
Amendment as absolutely essential to all
minority rights and majority rights is
do you think it's true that people you
know your age Millennials and younger
gen Z are they less uh resp respective
respecting of the First Amendment and a
free speech we know this we can look at
the polling result results fire has
conducted I think you have a majority of
college students now
support forcibly preventing people from
speaking on college campuses if they
consider their views
objectionable um and I think it has to
do with frankly power I think that you
know when progressives or the left were
out of
power they were more supportive of free
speech I mean why was the ACLU founded
it was founded to defend the rights of
Bolsheviks and anti-war activists around
World War I um and then you look at all
the major First Amendment cases I mean
not all of them but many of them involve
gay rights women's rights
African-American civil rights there were
some Nazis thrown in too sure uh and of
course the guy who led the Nazi Mar was
Jewish and gay sorry he was maybe partly
Jewish in in yeah he's a trifecta right
yeah and I think what's happened is that
as the left basically assumed power over
a lot of these institutions the media um
certainly the
academy once you're in power I mean look
people in power regardless of their
political views want to keep power okay
and it's and you don't um you're not
you're not uh there's not much of an
advantage to letting the opponent have
their say right you have to really
believe in the principle to do that and
so I think once these institutions
became sort of ideologically
monocultural um they just decided to
sort of rule them as like as as
ideological Thoms and when when was when
did that point you know when when was
the crossover in that because when when
did you graduate from college 2006 okay
and would you it wasn't as bad then I
was and I'll tell you for me a signal
moment was 2015 so it was 9 years after
I graduated it was and you're probably
all familiar with this or most of you
are was the Nicholas cacus Halloween
costume furor at Yale University when a
professor wrote an email to her students
telling them that Contra the university
dictat they should be free to choose
whatever Halloween costume they wanted
to wear um but also because she was like
dumpy a dick about it she I don't even
think she said that I think she what
what it what it started this was a an
administrator and most of these problems
on campuses begin with these Superfluous
administrators sent out an email to the
entire University with literally
photographs of Halloween costumes that
students shouldn't wear and one of them
was like a student wearing a taco or a
sombrero or a student in a Native
American headdress I mean really
patronizing to kind of explain to you
know 18 to 22y Old Yale students what
they should and should now wear that I
mean I don't recall there being any sort
of incidents regarding Halloween
costumes when I was a student at yeah
but apparently the situation had changed
by 2015 you were dressing up as the Baja
men right with your friends that just
went right behind me okay sorry never
mind all right we'll let it go but in
response to this a professor wrote to
her students saying look you're adults
you can choose what costumes you want to
wear if you don't like what one of your
peers are wearing why don't you have a
conversation with about it instead of
going to the administration and
complaining have a conversation as
adults and this led to all hell breaking
news and that footage her husband was
screamed at for 3 hours cursed at in his
face by a mob of angry students and I
watched this video and I felt like
civilization was collapsing like I this
would this would not have happened at
Yale when I was a student there less
than a decade before and so that to me
really signified that something had had
had sort of Switched yeah clearly
something and um uh John Jonathan hey
and Greg Lucan they pinpoint that yeah
they 2013 2014 they said yeah and they
talk about when students started
demanding speech restrictions rather
than administrator that was a
fundamental I guess my question is like
but weren't wasn't the left completely
in control of Yale when you were there
so you know I think liberals were I
think liberals were and I think what
we're seeing now is more of a
progressive yeah can you I think there's
a real distinction between liberals and
progressives I think liberals believe
small L liberals of which I consider
myself one I think you would consider
yourself one believe in individual
rights believe in might be free speech
absolutist to use that term that you and
I discussed actually believe you should
could be uh mandated to yell fire and
credit theaters falsely that's how much
of a liberal I am um and I think
progressives don't believe in those
things I think progressives believe in
group rights not individual rights right
so if an individual says something that
could be interpreted as offensive to a
group that therefore would be
impermissible because group rights
supersede individual rights that's so
that that to me I think is a fundamental
difference between and you think that's
mostly about power uh I I mean the
ideology ultimately it's really about
power and controlling
institutions I think they use these um
tools to yes to um stigmatize people um
to gain power in institutions and to
basically defeat and destroy their
ideological opponents yeah you've uh as
a journalist you've worked at a variety
of places and you publish in a variety
of you know places like the Atlantic uh
the new Republic public uh tablet
magazine um The New York Times uh air
mail Etc do you find is that split going
on there too the thing you know people
will always say well you know the media
has always been liberal you know by and
large but now it has shifted into
progressives or what's going on there is
it analogous to universities I think
there's a
generational difference between in a lot
of these institutions not just media I
think in publishing too
I mean let's look back on when Woody
Allen was going to have his book
published in Ronan
Pharaoh Rosemary's Baby uh raised a
Ruckus about this complaining and
demanding that the
publisher uh pulp the book and you had
all these editorial assistants the vast
majority of whom were under 30 years old
had a strike they actually left the
office to protest the publication of a
book to which I say why are you in
public publishing if you oppose the
publication of a book go work as a
censor in usbekistan or something like
this is not the career for you right and
and you can see this in all these
institutions there's a real generational
and I'm not saying everyone under 30s
like this okay and I'm not saying
everyone over 30 is on the right side of
this but you can absolutely see in these
institutions a generational divide you
talk to people of a certain age they
live in fear of their subordinates and
this I think is a real problem across
all these institutions it's a it's a
lack of liberals having a spine and
standing up to
progressives which is the same problem
on the right by the way okay what did we
see over the past seven or eight years
we saw mainstream reasonable Republicans
did not have a spine when it came to
Donald Trump and they just you know they
they it was like spaghetti they just
they just so where is that coming from
though then because if it's it's not
simply a liberal or conservative thing
because you're seeing it on the right
and the left that the extremes really
are totally running the debates right it
does seem that way absolutely and I'm
it's not just an age thing because a lot
of those on the right it's different on
on the right it's different you know I
don't know I haven't thought I haven't
thought about whether it's the same
phenomenon on both sides what are the
motivating causes um I think this for
for liberals it's very difficult when
they're confronted with an argument
having anything to do with sort of r
gender sexual orientation right if
someone's making um an argument from
positionality where it's like you know
as a you know transgender black whatever
as a gay man I tell you I think a lot of
liberals don't know how to respond to
that kind of argument they they they get
really afraid um and they have
difficulty sort of arguing from a from a
position of first principles to say you
know what it doesn't matter what you are
this is this is the principle that we
have like we believe in these ideals and
if you don't believe in them I don't
care what you are you maybe shouldn't
work
here uh with the Woody Allen book is it
does it matter I assume you believe
Woody Allen is not guilty of raping his
daughter I don't believe sorry I I I
believe he's innocent well I well look
there were two government yeah
investigations into this don't quote the
government at me now you're first of all
there there were no charges no charges
were ever filed if I'm not mistaken so
we have a legal system in this country
we have a system of justice he has not
been found guilty of any crime so and I
you know to the extent that I've looked
into it and I'm not like a Woody Allen
hobbyist I haven't but I've read I've
read enough you're not you're not old
enough yet give it another five years
right um but so by the way and so so so
to me it was Preposterous that one of
our most acclaimed filmmakers right
would have his book um
cancelled because of what I consider to
be spous allegations having nothing to
do with the content of that book which
the book was about his art about his
films I guess my question is if he was
guilty um if he was writing from prison
would you still feel the same way and
I'm not I'm not trying to catch you in
anything I'm just saying like what what
is is the principle like if you worked
at a publishing house and you know
there's this guy you know Hitler that
has a great book I think it's GNA go big
right um you know what what is the limit
of working at a place and saying you
know what we shouldn't be publishing
this thing and if we do I'm walking out
or I'm quitting I think that's a that's
a a decision that I would respect I
might not agree with it um but I would
respect someone saying you know what I
don't want to publish OJ Simpsons if I
did it right I can understand someone
working for Judith Regan at the time
deciding I don't want to do this in
which case you could find another job
but I don't think I don't think Woody
Allen was was that case and you feel
more broadly that we're we've become
overly sensitized as a society to being
afraid of making any kind of offense oh
absolutely yeah uh let's talk we're not
the worst though right Germany might be
worse I want to talk you know to run
through some of your uh some of the
articles that you published over the
last year or so to kind of clarify how
your free speech absolutism kind of
works out um for the Atlantic uh just a
couple days ago uh you wrote a piece
that was called or titled what happens
where free speech is unprotected the
subtitle is the case of a Maverick pist
who will go on trial in Germany for
using a Nazi symbol is a timely reminder
of the Liberty we should cherish I guess
I gave away the punch line of that but
but it's a good example who is CJ
Hopkins CJ Hopkins was a guy I met when
I was living in Berlin about a decade
ago he's a playright he's by his own
description he's an old Lefty I would
say he's close he's probably like a like
a gome if I had to put his
politics somewhere of that kind of
political dispensation he left America
in 2004 because he hated George W bush
and actually was one of the very few
he's he's one of those people who's
actually like I'm leaving the country
because of the election he he actually
did he actually left he couldn't have
taken David Crosby he actually left and
I got to know him because I was he he
taught like a script writing class and I
and I and I was taking this class and I
didn't really stay in touch with him but
he added me to his email list and he
beginning in two 2016 started writing
kind of political satire pieces um from
a very kind of you know old Lefty
perspective the pandemic rolled around
and unsurprisingly I guess he became uh
an antix guy he published a book which
is blurred by RFK Jr calling him our
modern Jeremiah and on the cover of this
book is a face mask with a SWAT sticka
on it so clearly what he's doing is he's
comparing masking policies in covid
vaccinations and the whole sort of
Public Health regime he's comparing that
to Nazism he doesn't like Nazism that
should be pretty clear from the point
you know the point that he's making the
German government is now Prosecuting him
for using a Nazi Insignia they're
alleging that he's promoting national
socialism so this just shows to me that
you know even though he's not violating
German law like you are you are allowed
to display the swasa in certain cases
you can't you can't go out and March
with a bunch of Nazis with with the
swatka in Germany but you're allowed to
use the swatka to and this is from the
German Constitution to protest
anti-constitutional activities now in
his mind and I don't agree with CJ on
this in his mind he's protesting what he
considers to be fascist policies right
making people get vaccinations and wear
masks to him to him is the equivalent of
the Third Reich personally I find that
ridiculous and maybe even offensive okay
as a Jew but this this is an abuse of
the German Constitution this man should
not be prosecuted he's not promoting
national socialism and I think it's
important because right now there was
another article in the Atlantic a couple
weeks before mine about what is
supposedly a massive problem of Nazis on
substack where a bunch of busy buddies
are going around now trying to get
substack to kick off people whom they
consider or term to be Nazis yeah who
who are some of the uh who who get well
the guy who started I don't I haven't
looked at his list I'm I'm suspicious
when people draw up lists of people who
should be silenced because yes could we
point to a couple of genuine Bonafide
Nazis who have subst newsletters sure
but what are they going to do when all
those Nazis are kicked off they're going
to find other Nazis okay and they're and
they're going to be people who again I
might not agree with but who should not
um be considered Nazis and should not
have their speech banned right so um
I just think this is an interesting case
because it shows you that even when you
are you know using a swatka in what in
my mind and in everyone's mind is
clearly intended as a as a mode of
criticizing Nazism you can still have
the government interpret it how they
want right it's always in the the German
government is acting like Nazis well
that's the thing you couldn't have seen
that kind well as I say in I say in the
piece if you're going to if you're if
you're going to punish people for their
speech and for and for accusing you of
being a fascist you're going to penalize
them for that you're kind of validating
the critique at that point right um
which uh brings to mind a piece that you
wrote for quette I think about a year
ago or thereabouts where about uh
calling out Alice walker uh and
everybody I suspect everybody in this
room has read The Color Purple which has
just been remade as a film yeah uh and
or seen the movie and there's two
versions of that um explain the context
of that what what were you calling out
Alice Walker for well I was at the
Mississippi Book Festival and she was
the I was speaking on a panel about my
book and she was the the keynote speaker
she's a notorious anti-semite I mean
just she endorses David Ike is that how
his name is pronounced David Ike who
believes that there's a kind of what
lizard people who control the world
basically many different conspiracies
and all these conspir and he was a
soccer player who then became a
commentator so is if Bob uker had become
a world conspiracist of lizard people
rather than being a Mr Bel and he thinks
that the Jews are you know part of this
lizard people he knows that yeah and
Alice Walker has engaged in some you
know this is not debatable the things
that she's said I mean she's really I
think she said that the Jews perpetrated
they are also complicit in the Holocaust
against themselves as a means of getting
Global sympathy look a lot of this might
stem from the fact that her ex-husband
is Jewish a lot you you actually you
find a lot of some of these crazy
anti-semites it all begins with the
Jewish X yeah which is not to which is
not to validate it but it is an
interesting but it is to explain it
perfectly
yeah um anyway she was invited as a
keynote speaker okay now I had a choice
I could have told the organizers how
dare you invite this anti-semite I find
this so offensive as a Jewish person
this is Despicable I'm going to you know
I'm not going to show up or you're not
going to have your big parties in
Mississippi anymore you're going to
boycott the state what I did was I used
I used uh an answer to a question that
someone had asked me to answer a
question and I said look yesterday I
visited the Civil Rights Museum here in
Jackson which is a great museum there's
a whole display on Jewish contributions
to the Civil Rights Movement um there's
a there's a prominent Rabbi in Jackson
who had his house firebombed in the
1960s all these details about about how
you know 2third of the Freedom Riders
were Jews you know two of the three
civil rights workers who were murdered
in Mississippi we're we're Jewish Cheney
sorry um Goodman and Scher and I just
said you know there's this great history
of cooperation between blacks and Jews
and I find it really unfortunate that
Alice Walker who clearly cares a lot
about civil rights and and her people
would um spit on that tradition I think
it's really shameful and I think that
she has a right to say these things as
Despicable as I find them but I have a
right to counter her and have my say and
that to me is sort of the model of how
we should deal with
these the crowd applauded and I think a
lot of people in the crowd probably
didn't know yeah about Alice Walker's
history of anti-Semitism did you uh you
also now I'm thinking back we've known
each other for years didn't you get was
it RT Russia Today which doesn't exist
anymore but does RT it's called it's not
Russia Today MSNBC
or no I guess they're not Russia Today
Fox is Russia today um but you was it on
RT when RT yes yeah you were uh this was
the last good uh uh example of using
rainbow suspenders to further the public
good could after after Ronald McDonald
or or who who else look nobody's wearing
rainbow suspenders anymore weren't you
wearing am I making that up it was the
summer of 2013 it was right around the
time that the Russian government was
passing these laws against the promotion
of
homosexuality the Duma had just passed
them a week or two before I happened to
be invited on RT to offer my opinion on
the sentencing of Chelsea who was then
Bradly Manning and I used that I was in
Sweden on vacation and I said yes I'll
do this obviously with the with the idea
and mind that I'm going to I'm going to
say something about these Dreadful this
Dreadful law that's being passed in
Russia and I I scrambled to find some
piece of of Gay Pride paraphernalia in
Sweden which was a lot harder to find
than you would think well it's
everywhere I I would have thought that
because it's such a gay country I had to
go Michel moan is laughing and he knows
exactly what I'm talking about uh think
uh his ex-wife who is Swedish is
laughing even more there's a reason she
immigrated oh god um I went to a vintage
clothing store and all I could find was
some rainbow suspenders
and this was a live broadcast and it was
it was weird it was in the Swedish
television
cafeteria that's where they that's where
they did this and I there were a bunch
of like fake plants behind me and so it
looked like I was in the waiting room of
some you know Suburban office building
and when I was asked to have my say what
do you think about the sentencing of
Radley Manning I pulled these suspenders
on and I shouted at the host for about
two minutes how dare you you should be
ashamed of yourself you know the you're
you're oppressing gay people this is
disgusting and they let me go on for
like two and a half minutes you can find
it on YouTube yeah um what
um let's uh talk about Bayard Rustin is
it Bayard or ber ber I always
mispronounce it um he is another civil
rights activist you wrote a great piece
in the fall for the New York Times
titled byed Rustin challenge Progressive
orthodoxies uh how did he do that who
was he and how did he by Ron was known
primarily as the chief organizer of the
1963 March on Washington a movie was
just made about him it's on Netflix it
was produced by the Obamas it's a great
film um it's a great story not a great
film but continue please um he um was a
former communist he was a conscientious
objector during World War II went to
jail for went to jail for two years and
a a black civil rights activist and um
he was also an openly gay man which you
know in the 1940s 50s and 60s was an
extremely rare and courageous thing and
in
1963 uh just a couple weeks before the
March actually STM
Thurman um outed him on the floor of I
mean he was out Rustin was out to his
you know colleagues Martin Luther King
knew that he was gay right but he was
not public and maybe that he was a
communist too yeah an ex-communist he
was actually very and I'll get on he was
very much an anti-communist um and just
a couple weeks before the March on
Washington STM Thurman he has a police a
police record of by Rustin being
arrested for having sex in a parked car
which you know if you were a gay man in
the
1950s um you were you were really living
under the threat of the law right
because the police were after you and he
exposed this to the country and what's
remarkable is that the leaders of the of
the
March stayed loyal to Rustin they didn't
fire him they kept him on and Rustin
would go on to be on the cover of Life
magazine he spoke at the March and he
effectively became the first public
figure in America to survive an outing
right to have his sexuality revealed and
he goes on to have this incredible
career um really emerging as a strong
opponent of um black nationalism of the
Black Panthers he's very much a class
leftist I think the arguments that he
was making about where the left should
go are very relevant to to today where
you see this debate going on between the
more identity based left and the
class-based left Russon was very much of
the opinion that the only way that
racial minorities in America were going
to progress was in Coalition with the
broad multi-racial working class um you
had to have a coalition you had to have
the labor unions you had to have Jews
you had to have all sorts of people
working together um he would go on to be
throughout the 1970s I mean a lot of
people accused him of being a
neoconservative in his foreign policy
views because he was virulently
anti-communist he you know he was not I
wouldn't say he was Pro Vietnam War he
was agnostic on the question of whether
or not the United States should have
been involved in Vietnam he was very
much opposed to a unilateral withdrawal
from Vietnam because he didn't want to
see the Communists you know take over
and turn the whole country communist um
he was involved in all these sorts of
initiatives um that were um uh concerned
with making the Democratic party more
hawkish with not sort of you know uh the
anti- George McGovern wi of of of the
democratic party he was strongly
pro-israel he started an organization
called the black American support of is
committee basic in 1975 a very outspoken
opponent of anti-Semitism in the black
community um none of that is in the
movie right the movie ends in 1963 he
has this fascinating political career
for the next 25 years of his life where
you know he remained very much a Social
Democrat he would have called himself a
socialist but he was very um I mean he
really opposed you know for lack of a
better term identity politics um you I
mean one of the things that you draw
from him and I I'll point out I uh our
last our previous guest in one of these
was Coleman Hughes who also looks at
Rustin as as a real kind of role model
um and um the book uh by Daniel ax War
by other means is about Rustin and David
delinger and it's it's fascinating it's
a immense history but kind of what
Rustin does and what you do is that you
show up and you you have the debate
right that's the main yeah he debated um
Malcolm X he debated stokeley k Michael
he debated you know all sorts of people
which I think is really lacking in our
political um Public public intellectual
dialogue today is a lot there are a lot
of people who don't who are who are
called public intellectuals who refuse
to debate and you know Coleman Hughes I
think is mult has tried many times to
get ibram X kendi to debate
him you know radio silence right and yet
and yet we uphold this guy as being the
leading public intellectual of our time
I'm sorry if you're a public
intellectual you got to debate people
who disagree with you yeah
what happened to that debate culture is
that a function of uh kind of media
sorting so that everybody now has their
own kind of Channel or platform or or is
it before that is that kind of looking
at the uh you know the outcome or the
the effect rather than the cause because
somebody nobody had to debate Bill
Buckley right who was a big debater um
in the 60s um you know what what
happened to that positive culture of
open debate it's a good question I mean
I was the president of my high school
debate team uh when I was at Yale I was
a very active member of the Yale
political union which is this great very
unique institution there's nothing like
it as far as I'm aware of an American
higher education it sort of if I may I
just want to point out I spoke there and
I immediately lost the debate when I
announced that it was great to be in a
room of people who like myself could not
get into Harvard
I should have saved that for the
afterwards the political union is sort
of a com it's sort of a combination of
the Oxford Union in the British
Parliament and that it's a debating club
or debating Society but there's parties
and there's parties from the farle
there's a left party which is socialist
basically all the way to the party of
the right which is this weird sort of
cultish you know Uber Catholic group but
every week we would come together and we
would debate and we would debate really
contentious issues we bring in a guest
do they still do that they still yes but
as I understand it as I understand it at
Yale over the past 15 years since I left
the left has sort of left the Y
political union they're out protesting
right they are involved in activism on
campus they're less interested in
participating in these debates with
their ideological opponents it's kind of
interesting in England which has very
you know ideological Outlets across the
board it seems like the debate the
culture of debate flourishes more so
it's probably not simply uh an epoh
phenomenon of media distribution right I
think I I it's it's a good question I do
feel though that that look I think with
the rise of partisanship more generally
in America and the rise of partisan
media I think it has made it um just
incredibly rare that there are Outlets
where you see a real um civil civil uh
intellectual debate of people and
there's all these initiatives now I mean
there's um the monk debates which I
participated in maybe which is in Canada
um there are all these sort of Civic
initiatives now that are sort of geared
at there's the Soho Forum a monthly uh
platform in New York City yeah and there
are some podcasts that I think try to
kind of cross the partisan open to
debate is another group that does that
formerly Intelligence Squared
us yeah but I mean I I just I loved
doing this when I was a kid yeah and I
would look forward it was kind of dorky
but I would look forward to going to
going into the ypu I mean my favorite
comedy sketch growing up was the Monty
Python argument store where a guy walks
in and wants to have an argument I mean
I I I love that right and I just feel
that you know you it really is a
generational change and and and just a
lot of these young people um believe
that words are a form of violence and
that words that words can do harm in in
the same way that violence can is this
is a kind of specific uh question rather
than than a broad one is do you think
anti-Semitism is a unique phenomenon in
the way that politics and
ideology is generated or gets polarized
and things like that you know I've been
thinking about this a lot obviously
since October 7th and I really think
that so much of what makes
anti-Semitism so unique and persistent
and protean it all goes back to
Christianity
it goes back to the Jewish rejection CH
I just want to point out you know it was
started by a Jew so don't get don't get
on the Christian case but I think even
if you look at leftwing I mean what so
what is the basis of Christian
anti-Semitism it's the Jews are
rejecting God right and they were never
forget it wasn't until the 1960s that
the Vatican overturned that so you have
Millennia of just you know murderous
anti-Semitism and I think it's so deeply
ingrained in Western society that even
left-wingers who are secular who hate
religion who hate organized religion who
hate the church they've been marinated
in this anti-semitic culture that
left-wing anti-Semitism Bears the strong
marker of this right because what is the
left-wing anti-semitic critique it's the
it's the Jews or the state of Israel
rejects international human rights the
Jews are stubbornly rejecting progress
that was that was the Soviet right the
Soviet you know it's it's the it's the
it's the Jews are are opposing our
Utopia and that's pretty much what the
Jew has existed as for Millennia it's
this Jewish rejection of kings of
utopian movements
right of refusing to get with the bigger
progr whatever the program is whether
it's an islamist program or a leftwing
program or a rightwing program what
about the capitalist angle of this
because this seems in the in America it
seems that
anti-Semitism is perhaps distinct from
European anti-Semitism which seems more
cultural it's blood and soil in Europe
you know and so like Jews you know and
this is you know so you have people like
ad Frank whose family had been in
Germany for hundreds of years was you
know at a at a certain point well like
you can't possibly be German um that
doesn't seem to be the same thing in
America right where people you know
people's backgrounds are more fluid or
or people Pride themselves on both being
American and a hyphenated version of
that yeah I mean look the reigning the
reigning form of anti-Semitism in
America until relatively recently I
would say was your you're
Gentile conservative if you want to put
a political label on the kind of Gentile
waspy Christian anti-Semitism we're not
going to let you into our country clubs
we're going to put quotas on your
attendance at our universities right
which is you know it's bad it's it's not
nice I think what we're dealing with now
is a lot worse which is a kind of islamo
Islam
leftist anti-Semitism that um you know
views uh Jews as being disloyal to the
country that is basically making Jews
choose between supporting Israel and
being considered loyal
Americans
um I I just I I personally find that
more viscerally frightening and I think
a lot of Jews do Post October 7th yeah
explain that um look the kind of the the
genal waspy anti-Semitism would have
never publicly exalted in the mass
murder of Jews right like
you uh that's what that's what happened
on October 7th on October 8th why why do
you think the left you know and it is
mostly on the left the you know the
extreme right is doing some kind of
weird kind of Christian fascist thing
but on the left it seems to be a a
linkage between Islam and anti-em
actually a little bit of a silver lining
in a lot of this leftwing anti-Semitism
and I think it's to a large degree a
species of
anti-white um sentiment rather than
hating Jews because they're Jews and
I'll explain what I mean by this you
know Jews are coded as white in this
sort of progressive woke now right they
weren't since since World War II I mean
if you ask you know uh the all the Wasps
who were on the board of Harvard in the
1950s are Jews White they wouldn't have
known how to answer that question I mean
Jews were not considered part of uh that
Community certainly not but in this new
kind of you know um woke dispensation
whatever you want to call it Jews are
coded as white and because so because so
much of
wokeness is frankly I I mean I don't
want to sound I mean it's basically just
anti-white
ideology you know Jews are actually seen
as worse than the average white person
because they are a minority who sold out
out and accepted a place in the white
Community right they sold they sold out
their um minority bonafides and they
assimilated it into the white power
structure which makes them like traitors
basically to the kind of you know
virtuous Coalition of the
oppressed and so I think and so I think
that's what's driving and so they look
at Israel and they see Israel as a white
country they see it as the modern day
equivalent of apartheid South Africa
that's why they use the word apartheid
so much is because they want to make
Israel a parias state in the same way
that South Africa was in the second half
of the 20th century and so Israel is a
white country it's oppressing a
non-white subaltern and I think that's
where a lot of this anti-Semitism comes
from so it's different from the sort of
traditional right-wing anti-Semitism
which is very much blood and soil and
and
racial this is more of a it's more of a
subset um a subspecies of of anti-white
ideology and this is coming out of post
Colonial Theory Etc what is there you
know what is the way to I don't want to
say reframe the debate because that
seems kind of weak a weak gesture but
what is you know how do how do we move
past the the moment we're in well I see
some people I don't I don't really like
this a lot of people respond to that
argument by saying hey look most
Israelis or a lot of Israelis are
actually brown and black and of color
and it's like yes that's true but it's
that sort of accepts the argument that
white people are a problem and are bad
and are oppressors like no people are
not bad because of their skin color end
of why is that so difficult yeah and
that I think is the ultimate problem
with this woke ideology is that it
reduces us to our immutable traits it's
just Reverse Racism who is who is the
left in America because it's a the the
left in America the people talking about
this are not overwhelmingly people of
color are they um no it's a lot well no
it's I think largely Progressive upper
upper middle class white people who are
really those whites well they're really
it's yeah it's my Progressive white
people problem in ours uh it's um no
it's like the robin D'Angelos and and
look because they don't they have to
overcompensate right because if you're a
white if you're a white person then that
means you don't have the the victim
status of a person of color right so you
have to go further you have to go One
Step Beyond in your progressivism and so
you see the kind of loudest and most
active um proponents of this ideology
are you know I think disproportionately
white
people um before we go to questions I
want to talk about one other story that
you wrote to uh a lot of uh attention
about a year ago and this was um for air
mail uh which is a new
subscription uh based uh kind of news
letter news platform uh this one is
called Army Hammer breaks the silence
two years after some of the most
shocking allegations of the me too era
lit up the internet and destroyed his
career the actor has finally decided to
tell his side of the story um again you
know we have gone from this world where
headlines really didn't tell you what a
story was about because they assumed you
would just read it because it was there
and now they actually kind of fetch you
in with something but uh who is Army
Hammer and what did you do in that story
that speaks to a real bizarre oversight
in contemporary journalism so yeah Army
Hammer is was a rather famous actor he
played the winkl Vos twins in the The
Social Network the movie about Facebook
he's the great grandson of Arman Hammer
the oil
magnate agent Soviet agent international
Man of Mystery um you know sort of a
leading leading man you know very
handsome young actor who in early
2021 was brought down by a series of me
too allegations and I actually think
that I say in the piece that it was
probably one of the most spectacular Meo
downfalls just the things that he was
accused of can which cannibalism for
instance was was one of the sexual well
sex yeah but not just rape and sexual
assaults but bizarre kinky sex fetishes
that he had branded he had carved his
initial in a woman's you know pelvic
area and that he had these cannibalistic
fantasies and his career just ended in a
in a week I mean it was it was
done and the story kind of went
away um until I was approached I was
approached by someone who was a
intermediary who said you know what
there's a lot more to this story that
hasn't been told and they offered me an
interview with hammer he hadn't spoken
to anyone in the
media and I spoke to him and the more I
discovered and the more I you know
researched this the more it became
apparent that there was a whole side of
this story that was not being told at
all I mean for instance his chief
accuser was being represented by Gloria
alled who some of you may know is a very
famous celebrity feminist
attorney Gloria alled dropped this woman
as a
client okay that's how you know TR how
trustworthy his main accuser was but
that wasn't picked up you know no one
else in the media decided to investigate
you know they had printed in all the
these stories they had printed his text
messages to women in which he's
expressing his um support for or his
expressing his interest in let's say you
know untraditional sexual acts having to
do with um SNM bondage and yes he wrote
about wanting to eat various parts of a
woman's body what weren't revealed in
any of these stories were the messages
that the women were sending back to him
which you would think might be an
element Al Elementary part of a
journalist duty is to not print one side
of a text exchange with someone right so
I got all the texts that he in and I and
I painted a a picture in which I'm not
absolving him of being a maybe a bad
person by his own admission he told me
that he was a jerk to some of these
women but again three months I'll just
say 3 months after my story appeared the
LAPD dropped its investigation and it
did not bring charges against him right
and it just showed me I'm not I'm not a
guy who covers celebrities I don't even
follow celebrity culture but this story
interested me because it was something
that seemed odd and fishy with like the
the the narrative that we were given
seemed odd and fishy and the more I
looked into it I realized this is just
completely um I mean the things he's
been accused of are not true but by the
time I printed my story yes I mean he
would eventually be legally absolved but
his career was in shambles and it just
shows you how easy it is in this country
to destroy someone's reputation in
career do you think it's worse now than
it was in the past or you know is
journalism shittier than it used to be
uh these types of things or how it's
hard to say do we want we don't want to
go back to the days when the media was
covering up the fact that FDR was a par
was a paraplegic
or you know suddenly it all makes
sense yeah but there were a lot of
things that the media wouldn't cover
back then right totally whereas now
it's gone completely in the opposite
direction I think where so many
journalists just do not do their basic
duty of expressing
skepticism you know when someone when
when when you have a source this is so
Elementary when you have a source in
journalism you have to have other
sources because your Source has an
agenda every Source has an agenda you
have to you have to check their
information against other um sources of
information and I feel that and this is
a problem that plagues both the right
and the left people have a narrative in
their head and they get one source to
confirm it and they run the story and I
just you know I look at one of the what
I think is one of the biggest
journalistic scandals of our time is is
the Russia gate story okay and I say
this to someone who's a Bonafide Russia
Hawk okay I've got you know I was kicked
off a live broadcast or Russian
television I worked for Radio free
Europe I am I I I was on you wrote a
book in 2017 called the end of Europe
dictators demagogues and the coming Dark
Age which is not protin not pro Putin
but and I'll say you know the first year
of the Trump Administration I kind of
went along or I was willing to believe
these claims that and the Russia gay
claims that Donald Trump was recruited
by the KGB or comprom they comprom
whether they comprom or he was
ideologically sympatico and was working
in cahoots with a foreign adversarial
power to seize control of the United
States government in a way that was
redolent of The Manchurian candidates
something like that I was willing to go
along with it for a while but then I
realized you know after this was a story
that was investigated I think more than
any other story in American history save
possibly the Kennedy assassination in
terms of the the the amount of resources
that went into this right all these PE
and they never came up with the goods
and I think this was a case of the media
wanting to believe something to be true
because they couldn't explain it any
other way and I look I I I lived a
sheltered existence in Washington DC you
know I'm a gay Jew from Boston I didn't
know a lot of trump supporters it didn't
make sense to me how he could have been
elected other than by you know the the
innate racism of half the American
people or some fishy scheme involving
the KGB in Moscow I'm admitting that
that's what I believed but my views
changed over time okay as as more facts
came to light or in this case facts
didn't come to light they still haven't
proven this but there are still I mean I
it still seems like a large portion of
the country is under the impression that
Donald Trump was recruited by the KGB in
the 1980s or somewhere around then and
that he's a foreign asset and and I just
I find that to be um a real failure of
of Duty the part you think that is like
there's no coming back from that or do
we learn a lesson and by we I mean I
think the med and the media prod I don't
think the media has learned a lesson
yeah do you think the mainstream media
has learned a lesson from this I don't I
I haven't seen many I haven't seen the
promoters of this conspiracy theory
recant yeah okay I maybe one or two of
them have I haven't seen Michael isakov
who co-authored a book Russian roulette
with David Korn he's he is Michael
isakov has kind of come out and said
look we got some things wrong nobody
reads him okay but David Korn has not
David K is you know doubled down on it
so and this is a problem like there used
to be consequences for journalists who
got stuff
that that I'm not sure no yeah I mean
May or in certain cases not that's where
maybe involving plagiarism or fat
outright Fabrications like Janet cook or
something yeah you know I guess my
question is you know part of it is that
you know more people can speak more
people can do journalism produce
journalism we consume it however we want
and kind of do whatever I mean it seems
to be simultaneously it is a golden age
for speech and for point of view and
it's also kind of like a nightmare cuz
the problem is that most people aren't
like us where we have a lot of time I'm
presuming you're in the audience or
you're listening to this podcast you
have a lot of time to to expose yourself
to different
sources most people don't do that most
people consume news in you know five or
10 minute bits they maybe read a couple
articles in the paper if they're even
subscribing to a paper most people
aren't subscribing to newspapers or
newspaper subscriptions have gone down
so yes I agree with you that it's it's
let let a million flowers bloom that's
important
but how many people are actually taking
advantage how many people are exposing
themselves to different ideological
positions oh I think it's more than it
is but it's also it's it's too much for
us I don't I don't know um just as a
final comment uh could you talk are you
optimistic about uh I I guess like about
America in general I mean this is
January 20124 we are in the kickoff
period of a presidential election that
nobody is excited by um uh you know is
are you excited or are you optimistic
about the future and if not in general
about you've turned 40 so it's all over
right I mean this it's all downhill from
here I think everybody in this room incl
the ones who are still awake would agree
with that um and uh but what about Free
Speech do you think free expression and
free speech is going to grow or is it
going to shrink and become more and more
Rich well look we have the first
Amendment right and as long as the first
amendment is upheld we're we're we're
going to be fine um what I'm more
concerned about legally right I'm not
I'm not concerned about people going to
jail for their political opinions what I
am concerned about is people self
censoring right is the culture of free
expression in this country seems to be
on the Wayne seems to be on on in in
Decline and we see this in polls again
pointing at fire fire has done polling
that shows that a a significantly higher
of a significantly higher percentage of
of Americans self-censor and are
concerned about expressing their
political beliefs than they were during
the McCarthy
era that's a really bad sign in my
opinion it's very and again I go back to
what started this it's kind of like
being in the closet it's like a country
of people who are in the closet which is
not a healthy place to be did it at
least make the sex
better we can say that for a future
episode thank you okay well we will I
want to thank Jamie kchi for talking to
reason
[Music]
you